all right
thanks everyone for joining me today my
name is hassam barakat and i work as a
tech lead with willow
this is my twitter handle and website if
you would like to follow me or reach out
to me with any questions
uh thanks for all of the attendees
please feel free to turn on your camera
and thanks for all of the people that
have turned
their cameras we have dave with his
amazing
and then that's amazing thanks dave
um today we're going to talk about a
domain driven design with
ef code i have been practicing with
design for a while now and one of the
things that i have noticed when i work
with developers is
how how can they apply
its value objects repositories domain
services
to the legacy code bases that they have
inherited from a previous team or a
third party event
and this is going to be the focus of my
talk today how would we apply domain
driven design
to a legacy code base and we will not be
only building a domain model that
exists in memory we'll also use the af
core
to materialize that domain model into
our relational database
but before we start let's go and define
what is a domain driven design
women driven design is an approach to
software development
that centers the development on
programming a domain model
that has a rich understanding of the
processes and the rules of the domain
so as developers we will be building a
domain model
so that leads us to what is a domain
model a domain model is an object model
of the domain
that has both behavior and data so
we will end up with a set of classes
that will not be just
set of data holders it will also have
behavior
usually behaviors with object-oriented
is functions or methods
so are we going to represent the whole
domain that we are working on
actually no because this is the other
definition that i really like about the
demeanor
the domain model it's a system of
abstractions that describe
selected aspects of the domain and can
be used to solve problems related to
that domain
so we will not be presenting every
single aspect that exists
in the business domain will be focusing
on the ones that will help us
solve our customer problems
so again domain model has behavior data
doesn't represent the whole
domain the thing to keep in mind
is as we add more and more features to
our domain model
our domain model will keep getting
bigger and
having a very large dummy model will
make it harder to understand and harder
to maintain
and this is where the strategic design
patterns from domain driven design
help us solve this problem and the
suggestion from the member is
to break that large momentum into a
small
bounded context or bounded contests so a
bounded context is a defined part
of the software where you use or you
have the terms definitions
and applied consistently so
clear boundary between different parts
of the system so
we can see here two bounded contexts the
sales and the support
both of them have different terms like
opportunity
territory in the support we have ticket
and effect
both of them could have same concept
like customer and the product
but within each bounded context the
customer is clearly defined
all of the developers and the business
experts have a shared understanding of
what is the customer mean within that
support context or within the sales
comments
so we when we have a large domain model
we should break it into
a bounded set of bounded comments today
we will not be focusing on how to break
that large domain model into multiple
bounded contexts but we will be focusing
on how would we apply the tactical
patterns from domain driven design
to upper context
but which one should we start with
increment design shouldn't be applied to
all of the bounded contexts that exist
in your system
because not all of them will gain value
from applying domain driven design
so if you have a bounded context that is
basically crowd operation like
managing set of categories you will not
get value from the
applying domain driven design or if you
have a product
catalog where you are listing them their
categories and
tags and stuff like that where you don't
have any business logic in there
you wouldn't get much value applying the
main given design
so keep in mind not all of the contexts
that
exist in your system should apply domain
driven design
so which one should you start with you
should focus your domain driven design
on or you start with the core domain
the core domain is the bounded context
that provides the most value to your
business it's that context that if you
remove
your business will exist this is where
you be should be starting and when you
find that other context
this is where you try to apply those
concepts like services
in these value objects and all of those
amazing tactical patterns
this didn't didn't help us to actually
see how would we apply those to legacy
code
this just pointed us to where should we
start
so in order to apply i will show you how
we apply the domain driven design to
legacy context
or legacy code base we will use a
standard domain
to show that uh as as we go and this
what we will expect
that is doing so the sample domain that
we have is
for a florist that florists have a
website
and it enables the customers of the
florist
to subscribe to products on a weekly or
a monthly basis
so a customer can subscribe to a small
weekly punch which
will cost them 50.
as the customers subscribe to more
products and they spend more money
with us we basically give them a
discount
this is a simplified domain from a
project that i worked on
and i kind of took part of that so that
we can go through
how we do that refactoring towards our
h2me model
the current domain model that we have in
the code base
will look like this we have a customer
class which has
email first name last name the amount of
money spent
and list of customer subscriptions we
have a list of products or a product
where you have amount
name telling period and whenever a
customer subscribe to a product
we calculate the uh subscription amount
is
the amount of money spent by that
customer if they are eligible for a
discount
we calculate when that subscription uh
will end and then we have a status
either active or classic
as you can see the current domain model
it's
it doesn't have any behavior and this
object model
is just data we have data email first
name
amount we don't have any behavior there
is no methods
and this is one of the key takeaways
today the
the rich domain model that you want to
have is a domain model that have
a behavior and that and this is what we
will be doing in our effect group
we will push more behavior towards our
knowledge
usually with legacy code bases the the
behavior
exists in the code but it's not in the
domain model it could exist in a
controller or could exist in a service
it could exist in a utility class
could exist anywhere and our key
objective is to push that behavior
the domain behavior to be part of the
domain model so we end up with that
object model
that has paul's behavior and death let's
switch to
the idea so that we can read the code
base and start seeing how would we
refactor it towards a rich domain mode
this is a typical code base it's built
with net core
that's having the domain the controller
here
which is exposing an api we will focus
on a specific use case today which is
a customer subscribing to our products
so we have a request
and the code base is using the mediator
library which is an excellent library
from jimmy bogard
that enables us to make our the methods
in
in our controllers really small and we
have
a specific handler that can handle the
request either it's a query or a command
and this also makes it better from a
testing perspective
so the request that we have right now is
a subscribe request
that has a customer id and a product id
i'm passing the customer id as a
parameter because i don't have
authentication in this sample codebase
and we can see here the handler of that
request
which is doing the the following logic
with the actual handling report loading
the customer information from the
database
loading the product information from the
database
calculating the subscription amount
based on
the product amount and how much did that
customer spend
in our goods it's simplified logic here
if the customer spends more than a
hundred dollars
they will get a 20 discount if they
spend more than a thousand dollars they
will get
50 discount very generous with our
customers so
this is where we do the calculation of
the subscription amount
the next part here at line 47 is
calculating
when that current subscription will end
the current period specifically
so if it's a weekly subscription it will
end in seven days
if it's a monthly subscription it will
end after a month
the next part that we have in this
method is
creating a subscription uh there is a
request to increase the phone size i
just do that
and just make sure everyone can see it
i hope that's better calculate creating
a subscription instance
adding the instance to the customer
subscription
increasing the amount of money spent so
the next time the customer
subscribe to a product they we calculate
the discount correctly
the next step is saving the all of those
changes to the database and sending an
email to the customer
letting the letting them know that they
have subscribed to our group
so as we can this method has a lot of
behavior
and this is in this particular set
the behavior exists in handler rather
than being part of the domain
and what we will try to do today is push
some of that behavior to be part of them
while we are applying all of the
tactical patterns as we do
currently the domain classes exist in
this domain directory where we have the
customer
product and subscription all of my
entities inherit from a base entity that
is
having the primary key for that
identifier of this entity
i'm using ef core um to materialize the
data
to the database or materialize the
domain model
hence we have a subscription context
that has a property for each
working on and i'm using the fluent apis
to map my domain model to the database
and this is important because
we don't want to cluster our domain
model with any of the rm concepts we
just
want to keep the focus of the domain
model on the business part
hence having a fluent apis is really
important
we don't want to have those required
table
attributes on top of our domain model
properties
so this is important so this is how the
code looks like right now
and we have obviously migration and the
service of sending data
so how can we return this model to
be a more overreach to my model see this
is a very long method that is doing a
lot of
logic inside of it so what i will start
with i will break this method into a
smaller methods
in legacy code basis you might have some
hints like comments or regions that help
you identify
how to break that large set of a large
method into smaller
methods so we break this logic to a
smaller set of methods
so the first one here is pretty easy
calculating subscription amounts
so i'll extract the method from this
[Music]
then i will extract another method for
calculating the current subscription
period in dates
the last part is by basically creating
the subscription
adding it to the customer so let's
create another method
and we will call it add subscription to
customer
[Music]
or what we have done is we have
simplified the method
uh that we are refactoring which
basically minimize the magnetic load
that we have in order to understand this
method
all right let's go and view each of
those methods and see what are the
issues that we have
and how we can push that here to be part
of the
model the first method here is adding a
subscription to customer
i can see a few issues with this method
the first one is
the creating a subscription itself is
done by the object initializer
and this means that
we can do those mistakes of instead of
creating
the description in an active status they
can go and create it in cancel
and although from a code perspective
that's valid from a business perspective
that's wrong you should never
create a subscription that's in cancel
the states
subscription always starts with active
so that the main model is not stopping
the consumers from making those mistakes
similarly
i can create a subscription without a
customer or without a product right
and i will not get any exceptions from
the domain model i might get an
error when i try to materialize the
domain mode into the database but that's
we should have all of those business
logic or business behavior to be part of
the domain mode
thankfully with c-sharp we can use the
sub the constructor feature to
encapsulate that logic to be part of the
subscription
and instead of having those publicly set
properties they can be
privately set which means we can modify
them only by behavior that exists in the
domain model itself
so i have a code snippet for that
so here is my subscription constructor i
have created a new instance
of a new constructor that accepts
the required parameters to create a
subscription
and as you can see here i started
applying validation
to my constructor so if i try to create
a
subscription without a customer i will
get an exception if i try to provide a
negative amount
i will get an exception and as you can
see i have
in immediately set the status to active
and the consumer of the main model
doesn't need to worry about that
since i have updated the constructor
let's update the consumer code use that
parameterized constructor
so we have pushed the construction
behavior to be part of the domain model
i have a single test here that will help
me
i couldn't break that code obviously in
existing code basis
you might have more tests and if you
don't have any tests then this is maybe
what you should start with
which introducing tests to your coping
let me run the test to make sure nothing
is broken
i'm getting an exception here and the
exception would say
there is no suitable constructor and the
reason
is this is a limitation from core
because
if core cannot create an instance of
an entity that has a parameterized
constructor
is specifically when you have parameters
in that constructor
that are navigation properties like
customer or approved
and the solution to that is to introduce
a private constructor
because we don't want the consumers of
our own model to
uh use that parameter-less constructor
but it can be used by avcor
some some people would prefer to
have a separate domain models
separate models one domain model to
include all of the behavior
and all of the persistent logic like
to avoid having stuff like private
constructs
but in my opinion with all of the
improvements that are coming to
rms like af4 uh i don't think this is a
big
issue and i think it could be okay to
keep progressing with a single domain
because this is not really
like a big to my domain model
let's run the test now and make sure
nothing is broken and if we
can construct that
subscription in
our passing and now we have pushed that
behavior
to the subscription class
the next thing that we i can see here
with this subscription
class is
the the developers consuming
subscription need to always remember
to update the amount of money spent
whenever they add or remove or
change the subscription collection so
this relationship
is basically needs to be always
kept in mind whenever you work with the
subscriptions list
and the way i say that this behavior is
something that could be pushed to be
part of the domain model and
consumers of my class shouldn't even
need to worry about
modifying the money spin it should be a
read-only property
and it should be modified by a behavior
within
so i can push this whole behavior of
adding subscription to a customer
to be part of the customer class like
this is how would i add a subscription
to a customer
i will add those parameters and this
behavior of modifying
the money spent become part of the
customer
so let's do that i will use the
reflection
that i have from writer and i will make
this add subscription to customer to be
an instance method
in the customer class now we have a part
of the customer
we can rename it so we don't have the
two customers since we are part of the
customer worries
since i have moved the behavior to be
part of the customer i can modify the
money spent to be privately set
rather than publicly set so the consumer
right now
doesn't need to worry about completing
the money spent whenever
they subs whenever they add a
subscription to the bus
so we have done a refactoring let's run
the test to make sure nothing is broken
there are different approaches when you
work with this refactoring uh some
people prefer to use
a factory method that's also an option
uh if you want to have uh or like domain
uh
services option it depends on the
business
and the business depends on the case
that you have here so
in this case i think adding a
subscription is working fine
but again the consumers cannot
go away with or actually can go away
with doing something like this
subscription clear
the consumers of the subscription class
can still go and modify
the list of the subscriptions and this
will create the relationship between the
money spent
and the subscription collection so what
we can do here is
um we can go and
modify our customer class so instead of
exposing
a mutable list we can expose a read-only
list
so what i have here is a list class
let's say
using the list class which inherits from
i read only and i read only it has from
irid only collection
so i can expose pirate only collection
and use a packing field
rather than exposing a mutable list
so i have a little snippet for that
so you won't need to watch me writing
and i will update my method to use
the privacy so i have exposed i read
only collection
and i have a private field which is
holding that list right now
at this point although i don't have that
clear method exist
but nothing stopping me from casting
this
subscriptions to be a list of
subscriptions and then i can hold them
up
if i do this right now it will work and
that should be that wouldn't be an issue
and to avoid having that scenario and
cover it as well
we should be using a mister that's
called as only
and this will a wrapper around
my list and it cannot be modified in the
run time so right now if i try to
call this clear method i will get an
exception
so now we have in behavior
to be part of my customer class and what
no one can break
that relationship between subscriptions
and
the money spent and whenever i want to
modify the subscriptions list i can do
it by
the private feed let's run the test and
make sure
nothing is broken after the refactoring
right passing so let's recap what we
have done so far
the first thing that we have done is we
have taken that very long handler
to have a smaller methods so we had a
method for calculating transcription
amount
the current period ended and adding
subscription to customer
we started reflecting the add
subscription to customer
uh first we uh we we moved
the behavior of constructing a
subscription to be part of
the entity itself and we use the
constructor to validate the parameters
coming to the subscription
who encapsulated the logic of adding
subscription to customer to be part of
the customer entity
and we encapsulated the behavior of
modifying
the subscription management so both of
them became
read only the management is by a private
set so you can read the value
and we encapsulated the behavior of the
read-only collection using
everyone now more behavior
moved from the hand left to be part of
the domain mode
let's get back to our handler and see
the next method that we have extracted
and what what do we have in here
this method is interesting because it's
a static method which is calculating the
current
period indeed it's a static and accepts
a single parameter which is
the problem whenever i see this pattern
of
having a static method with one
parameter this usually
could be an indication that
the whole behavior belongs to the
product so
instead of having the behavior as a part
of the handler we can move this whole
behavior to be
part of the product fast and this is
what i'm going to do
so i move this behavior and i'll make it
an instance method of
the product so now it's part of the
product
one thing to keep in mind here is we can
see there is a switch statement
on the billing period and the billing
period is an enumerage
in in the legacy code pages one of the
smells that you might find in the code
base is
there could be multiple locations in the
code base where are
you could have multiple switches
statements
or if else conditions on that particular
emulation
and the problem with that is if you
would like to introduce a new value
for the enumeration like in in this case
introducing a yearly subscription
it would mean that you would need to go
and update all of those
touch points in the code one thing
you can do if you have that case is we
factor this
enumerator to be an enumeration class
and refactor those switches statements
to be part of a strategy pattern
implementation
i wouldn't show you that today because
we don't have the case but if you are
interested
the code is available in github and will
show you of this sample is available in
github with a sample
of refactored enumerator to enumeration
class
i will reference the link of the source
code at the end of the book
so for this case we will just keep it as
a part of the product
and we just run the test to make sure
nothing is broken
so nothing is broken that's amazing
let's start looking at the next method
that we have here
which is calculating the subscription
amounts
calculating the subscription amount is
uh has
that it's a static method and it has two
parameters the first the product the
second one is the customer
so we cannot basically just move it to
one of the
entities because maybe in this case we
don't have the behavior to
fit well into one of the entities and
the domains becomes very handy which is
basically it's a clause that could have
a behavior
that doesn't belong to one particular
entity and it could be accepting the
input as multiple entities
work the behavior in there and return
the outcome
and this is what i'm going to do today i
will introduce a domain service
to calculate the subscription amount so
i go here create a class we call it
subscription amount calculator
and this class will be the one to hold
the behavior that we have in our request
handle
so i will use the refactoring from a
sharper to move
this behavior to be part of subscription
amount calculator
and the sharper is pretty slow because
i'm streaming
found our class and we move it
to move this behavior to be part of the
subscription amount category
since we are working with classes i
prefer to
develop again as an interface because it
makes my testing
easier so what we will do is we will
make this an anesthetic method and then
we will introduce we extract an
interface
of this class so we can do that
by extracting interface
we will call it oh let's already have
the eye
and we can push this member to
up remember up and will be part of
the page interface so now i can update
my
handler to accept the interface as a
dependency and then use that
domain service dependency to calculate
the subscription amount
rather than using as a part of the code
so i subscription amount
later then we call it here
introduce private field
then we go with
and now we have a new dependency and
obviously we need to update the test
to use this new domain service it's
going to go
and we'll pause this dependency
one thing to notice after introducing
that dependency is
the outcome of this dependency is passed
to
subscription add subscription of the
customer
and also this the subscription is
accepting
product so inside this method i have the
product
and the customer at the same time so
what i can do i can
take this one little bit further which
is pushing that behavior of
calculating or calling the calculate
method in the
subscription amount calculator to be
part of my domain
so rather than passing the outcome i can
pass
the actual a calculator and use the
double dispatch
pattern of pathing the customer and the
product to the
to the domain service so what i will do
here is
just undo this by changing this method
to accept
iso description amount calculator just
that and instead of
using the subscription amount directly
just give it a variable here
basically holding the value of calling
the domain service
i will be passing the product which i'm
already getting as a parameter
and then i will pass the customer which
i am part of the customer already so at
line 19 i'm
passing an instance of the customer
class
to the domain service this mean the
whole
calculation of the subscription amount
doesn't need to happen as a part of the
handler it will happen as a part
of the domain logic itself
so now i have behavior and i should run
the test to make sure that i didn't
break my method
all right that is our passing let's go
and recap what we have done
so far after encapsulating the
collection we pushed the behavior of
calculating the current period end date
to be part of the product class
we talked about the potential using
usage of the enumeration clauses
if you have multiple locations in your
code base with
if else or switch statements over the
enumerator
the next thing is we have introduced a
domain service
and that domain service had the logic of
calculating subscription amounts
and we the reason we introduced the
domain service is
to either the product nor to the
customer
finally we use the double dispatch to
pass or to call the domain
as a part of the domain logic rather
than as a part of the hand
so as you can see our handler had all of
that logic as a part of it
and most of the project were belonging
to or better to be pushed to the domain
model because now we have a richer
domain model with more
data and behavior rather than data only
the next thing that i can see in this
handler class is
sending an email to the customer
obviously it's very simplified it
doesn't even
actually send an email but it's just to
give the idea when
something happens in the domain like a
customer subscribe to a product
as an application we would like to
notify the customer that they have
subscribed to that product
so sending an email is definitely part
of the application but instead of doing
it as a part of the handler itself
we can trigger that email sending
activity or function
once a domain event happen in my domain
so this is where the domain event
concept becomes in handy
and the way we can introduce it to our
domain
is let's go switch to the slide and show
you how it will actually work
so all of my classes inherit from a base
entity
so what i would like to do is whenever
an action or behavior happen in my
domain entity
to add or raise a domain event
and i will raise that domain event by
having
a list of domain events in the base
entity
and whenever the action is called i will
add an
entry to that list of domain events
then whenever the db context say the
changes method is called
we will be leveraging the five segment
to listen to that behavior that the save
changes method has been called
then we will be leveraging the db
context
uh change tracker to find all of the
entities
in the db context that has a list of
domain events
we'll loop over those entities and we
will be using the mediator
library to publish those domain events
the publish method from mediator enables
have that pops up mechanism
and it means i could have handlers
listening to that domain event
and processing the logic required for
that domain event so
if we have a domain event called
customer subscribe to our product
then we can you have a handler that will
send an email to that customer
or maybe send an email to uh
the shipping or do something else
one thing to keep in mind as you you can
see i keep using the past tense when i'm
describing my domain events and this is
what you should have in your
classes because the main event is used
to describe that
something that has happened in the past
something that is already happened
so my domain events usually use the past
tense in their names
so let's see how would we actually go
and see this in action
first of all we need to introduce a base
interface that can be used by all of the
domain events
so in the shared kernel here i'll create
an interface and we'll call it
i domain event
since that domain event is going to use
the mediator
i am going to make it inherit from i
notification class
from the mediator library then
i will update the page entity to have a
list of those domain events
so we have a read-only list and we have
a feature
that enables us to update or modify
those domain events so the inhere the
the entities that inherit from the base
events whenever behavior happens like a
customer subscribe to our product
they can add that event to the list of
domain events
i will create a new directory to code or
name space to have my
events and i will create a class called
customer subscribe to product this is
going to be my first domain event
[Music]
and then this should inherit from i
domain
i have a good snippet showing the actual
domain event with the handler of it so
let's
have that remember the main service
here we go here is the actual domain
event
and the parameters of the domain event
or the properties of the domain event is
the customer that subscribe to the
product and which product they subscribe
you i know the handler from mediator so
whenever the domain event is raised or
published
we can listen to that domain event here
and as you can see here at line 27
i am sending the email
the last part to do is when the customer
subscribe to a product of the house
where the next part
is raising that domain event so
we will add a custom subscribe to our
product
event here so i'm calling the method
from the base class called
add domain event which will basically
add to that list of domain events
so what we have done so far is updating
the basic
based entity to have a list of domain
events
we have event we have introduced an
event with an event handler
the last page of this
it changes interceptor which is usually
going to use the ef core
uh file functionality which i have
cheated a bit here and i have that
clause commented out so i'm going to
comment
uncommented and let's read the code
together
so in order to listen to those save
changes events from e4
you can introduce inherit from a class
called save
changes intercept save the change
interceptor can be registered to the
dependency injection
uh framework that you are using and
hence you can use
it or you can inject any dependency that
you have in your code so
enzyme injecting the mediator in my
construct
then we can this basically enables us to
override the safety changes
and the ascent method of save the
changes are sync
whenever the save changes method is
triggered this will enable us to
dispatch the domain
you can see here that line we are using
to find all of the entities in the
context
that have domain events inside of them
then the next step here is looping over
those
entities and finding the domain event
using mediator to publish those domain
events
one of the things to keep in mind when
you have this pattern
is the the resiliency what happens if
you send
an email and you fail to save the
database the changes or you save the
database
changes and you fail to send the email
that the order of events here is
important
usually the next step when i i work with
this pattern is
i separate those behaviors into two
separate processes
and the user pattern from the store and
forward or it's also called an
outbox pattern where instead of
immediately publishing the domain events
i save the domain events into a table in
the database
and then i have another process that
read those events
and basically process them or publish
them to a service bus
to be by the consumers
we will not do that today but this is
something to keep in mind when you work
or
start introducing the main events
since we have introduced a new class we
need to make sure that that class is
registered in our di container and
uh the the domain event dispatcher can
be registered as a scope
service and when we add the db context
from af core we can use the overload
that accepts a service provider
which means we can call a method called
get service
and that will mean that the domain event
dispatcher will be resolved from the di
and not only the the classes also all of
the dependencies
in that class now we have everything in
place
we should be able to run this i don't
have really test covering all of those
areas but i just want to make sure that
the behavior
hasn't been proposed ideally you should
start having more tests
like this for domain event dispatcher
and
the actual domain event the actual event
handler i should say
and since we have introduced the domain
event handler i can remove
this whole logic of sending the email
from my handler because
it's no longer required here i can
remove
this email sender it's now handled via
and handler so my lunch is much simpler
right now
and even my test will be simpler because
yet another dependency
removed running the test and
everything
great nothing is broken
so let's recap what we have done because
i know this is a little bit involved
we have added the list of domain events
list using the
save the changes interceptor from ef45
it changes find using the change of
tracker to find all of the entities that
has domain events in them
publish them to the mediator having the
event handlers to handle those domain
events
so far all of the refactorings that we
have been doing will trigger the based
on
smells in the code like having it
with a single parameter or having a
behavior that is stopping the consumers
from
constructing an entity in the right
variant basically but this is not always
the case when you work with domain
driven design because
one of the important things with ddd is
having a continuous collaboration
with the business experts we should try
to make your domain model
have use the same language used by the
business expert
and this is where they the epiquitas
language part becomes really important
so some of the reflections will not be
triggered from
the coded smiles it will be triggered
from the conversations that happens with
the main experts
a simple example within the tactical
patterns is
let's say we are talking with the
business experts and they always use the
term
i want to show the customer name in the
report i want to show the customer name
in this particular and we keep
using that customer name all the time
but they never go and say
i'm sure um they never talk about the
customer name in terms of
customer first name middle name last
name or customer first name last name
we always just refer to the customer
name so at that point
it might be a good idea to start using
value objects
to represent the same concepts or the
same lag or use the same language
that the business experts are using
so instead of having customer first name
last name as a part of my customer class
i can refactor that to use a value
object
value object as a concept means if we
have
two instances of a value object both
instances will be equivalent
if all of the properties of the value
objects have
are equivalent so this is basically
lands itself
well with the c sharp nine records
it's pretty much the exact definition so
what we can do instead of using
a series name last name we can introduce
a record
as our value so what we can have here
is cnn record
there's going to be some uh highlighted
alerts here because the plane rider
doesn't support
c-sharp records fully yet uh so
ignore those highlighted errors as we
will see when we run the test it will be
working fine
so now we have pushed created the
customer record
i can use that customer record in my
class
and even better as we have done with the
subscription
i can introduce a constructor and pass
that customer name as a parameter of my
construct
so i will remove those properties and
replace them
with constructor and privately cells
properties so here is my private
constructor to be used when you load
the data from the database because of ef
core limitation with parameterized
constructor
i can pass the customer name as a
parameter of my constructor
having my validations here and here is
my
property it's privately set and can be
modified only via
methods within my customer because this
is part of the behavior
now we have introduced the customer name
i should update my test
to the to use the customer name and the
constructor that we have introduced
i'll use the wrong constructor
the constructor
and we can see that the test should be
passing right now
but actually the code wouldn't compile
because we didn't
do the configuration of how would we
customer name record to be using the
same fields
in the same table of the database and
this is where the
core own entities becomes really
important and valuable
features that we can leverage so instead
of directly using
the builder here in the fluent api i can
go and say
phones one not that one
so builder that owns one this enables us
to
introduce a value object or map a
particular property
and then within that one we can define
the properties we then
within the this builder is the
columns in the same table one thing to
keep in mind here is
the default naming conventions of own
owned entities
is the table name underscore the column
name so
if you are working with the legacy
called days which probably you need to
use the explicit column name and one of
the benefits of using ef quark 5
is now previously it would be of course
previous versions the default behavior
of all the entities that they were
nullable
but right now this is a with this
navigation
method we can define if it's optional or
required
and also we can define for each column
if it's optional required
and if you generated migrations or
either sql or code migrations from this
on empties
it would be mapped correctly now the
mapping is done
if we run the tests it should be passing
let's run that
amazing that this has passed so let's
recap what we have done so far
after domain entity we moved away from
using
the primitive parameters like the string
for
string first name and string last name
to value objects
and that enabled us to have a domain
model that
is using a consistent language and the
same language used by the business
experts
we have also used the owned entities to
map those properties
to the same columns in the database
table
and we leveraged the new navigation
method from here for
the database that those columns or this
property is required
the next thing that i want to talk about
is in my code days you haven't seen any
repositories
and usually one of the things that you
have seen with legacy code basis is
repositories all over the place
repository
empty or generically possible and this
is a sample of a repository that you
might see in a legacy code base
you could have something repositive for
a customer where you have git customers
get customer by id
and save usually these repositories are
okay
but sometimes they have landmines like
this save method
because save method here is calling the
context saver changes
and context saver changes will send all
of the changes
not only relevant to the customer entity
to any entity to the database
and this mean if i have a service and
that service is
consuming multiple repositories at the
same time
and calling the save method in each
repository we might be calling the
database multiple times
unintentionally so this is something
that you
should be aware of in in some solutions
that i have seen
is introducing the unit of work pattern
to
avoid having saved method in each
repository
you would have something like this you
would have a unit of war
the unit of work depends on the
subscription context or
the dp context in general and then you
have a saved method
that's calling the context-saving
changes behavior
as a part of that unit of war that could
be a potential solution
but in my in my in my mind this solution
is
introducing unnecessary dependency
because
the subscription context itself is a
concrete class
that we are earning and maintaining so
instead of introducing yet another unit
of work plus
we can embrace the subscription context
to become our unit of work
and that would be the one that would
have that save changes commit begin
transaction brought back
all of those behaviors that we would
like to have as a part of the unitable
and if we are worried about the the unit
testing part
we can leverage an interface and we use
the interface as
the dependencies that we inject to all
of the consumer classes
the queries where is to read data like
getting the customer or getting the
subscription and so on
the the queries in general one of the
things that i have seen when you use the
repository pattern
is you end up with those very big
repositories
that have get customer by first name
customer by last name
customer by first name
there are other solutions out there that
could help with
improving and solving those problems
that unfortunately you wouldn't have
enough time to go
over each of them but i'll give you the
name of the pattern so you can
look them up after the talk and i'm
happy to show you examples of them
so the three patterns that i think would
help you having
a solution and avoid that big repository
class
is using something like the query
classes or specification pattern or the
extensions with
extension methods those pattern will try
to make
like a specific queries or a very usable
queries encapsulated
and you can use them in multiple places
but at the same time
we didn't end up with very very big
repositories
there are a lot of samples out there
about those patterns fortunately we will
not be able
to go through all of them today
the next thing that i want to talk about
is the
the entity identifier as you have seen
in my codebase
i am inheriting it from a grassfull
entity
and in your code you might have a
different type you might not have a
geoid if you are working with the legacy
code because it might be integer
or sometimes i have seen some entities
with integer
and the newer indices are with gid
so we you could make that entity based
entity class
a generic clause that accepts any type
of identifier
and even better move away from having a
specific
primitive type or like integer and use
a strongly typed identifier like using a
value object represents
the identifier of your entity so for
customer you could have a customer id
subscription you could have a
subscription id
the good thing with using those strongly
typed identifiers
is first we can introduce validations in
the constructor of that
value type so if i have a guid i can
ensure that the geo id
is not an mtg id so
adding a validation you never have a
file other thing is if you have a method
that accepts multiple
identifiers you wouldn't have the
mistake of passing
the geo id of the product to be the idea
of the
customer because it's a strongly typed
language and we can leverage that
feature when we are building our code
base finally if you have a legacy code
bait and you're refactoring from
let's say integer to guid you wouldn't
need to update your whole code base
to uh move from integer to grid because
you could basically be using
that strongly types identifier so
behind
so that's something to keep in mind you
might not be able to do the positive
when you are effecting your legacy
legacy called base but it's something to
keep in mind and you should be aiming
towards as you progress with your
improvements
uh that's all what i wanted to cover
today
uh i will be looking for the questions
over the slacking channel
uh if you have any questions please put
them there
i will also share the slides as well as
a sample code that we have seen today
uh in the slack channel and since uh
thanks
i want to thank all of you and microsoft
australia for sharing some
who will swag with you so um those are
the first link is a link to join a news
with a newsletter and
it's has a lot of valuable information
if you want to grab the coolest swag you
can go to that link of
from microsoft and you can use the code
available here to in your swag it
just uh it's going to be for only the
first four
entrants so not everyone will get the
swag but
hopefully one for you will get that
sweat
um thanks again for your time i hope you
enjoyed the talk
and uh yeah i i hope you enjoyed the
rest of the conference today
thanks a lot
you